[Music]
since the dawn of time
we have raised our eyes to the sky
observing
and dreaming
of the unknown worlds that the universe
might shelter
imagine that we could leave earth
and travel through space and time
in order to explore these inaccessible
places
discovering the cosmos
[Music]
we are one and a half billion kilometers
away from the sun
seen from here our star is no more than
a dot
lost in an immensity
in front of us
stan saturn
[Music]
it is the sixth planet of the solar
system
[Music]
saturn is a huge ball of gas
ten times larger than earth the gas
giant's diameter measures nearly 120 000
kilometers
for a mass of 500 000 billion
billion tons
being so far from the sun
it takes almost 30 years to orbit around
it
[Music]
here
one year amounts to 11 000 days on earth
[Music]
the very thick atmosphere of saturn
is composed mainly of hydrogen
to which is added some helium
and traces of other rare gases
these gases which are very light provide
saturn with a remarkably low average
density
if it could be submerged in a large
enough ocean
it would float on the surface of the
water
[Music]
[Music]
covered in yellow and orange colors
sutton's atmosphere is far from uniform
its color is due to the chemical
elements that compose it
[Music]
it sometimes presents blue shades
resulting from complex phenomena related
to how light scatters
these are the same phenomena that give
our sky its blue colour
on earth
[Music]
on saturn's surface a freezing
temperature of negative 180 degrees
celsius prevails
gas clouds circulate around the planet
and form a stack of horizontal
[Music]
stripes in this incessant flow it
sometimes happens that huge
thunderstorms form
these extremely powerful electric storms
can last for several months and extend
over thousands of kilometers
giving rise to raging winds that can
reach incredible speeds
[Music]
[Music]
at the north pole
the course of the winds draws a very
strange cloud pattern
its mysterious hexagonal shape has yet
to find a definite explanation
in ultraviolet light
we can also distinguish magnificent
auroras
[Music]
these intriguing polar lights
similar to those found on earth arise
from the interaction of solar winds with
the planet's magnetic field
saturn is surrounded by an impressive
system of concentric rings
these rings are made up of fine
particles of ice and dust
which revolve around the planet
extremely thin
they are only a few dozens of meters
thick
while spanning hundreds of thousands of
kilometers in radius
the origin of these rings is still a
mystery
they are perhaps the remnants of a moon
which would have ventured too close to
the planet
torn and distorted by the attraction of
saturn it would have eventually exploded
pulverized by the planet's tidal forces
[Music]
saturn is outrageously massive
it's very strong gravitational influence
allows it to keep in orbit over 60 moons
some of these moons orbit inside the
rings
among them for instance
is pan
orbiting within the anchor gap
its gravitational pull deflects the
trajectories of surrounding particles
[Music]
the periodic passage of the satellite
forces this division to stay open
and separates the rings which are
situated on either side
this is prometheus
pandora
[Music]
prometheus and pandora are two shepherd
moons which work together
orbiting very close to each other the
two moons deflect the trajectories of
particles around them
and force them to be confined inside a
very narrow ring
barely a hundred kilometers wide
as we move away from saturn and its
rings
we encounter a wide variety of moons
[Music]
each of them with unique characteristics
240 000 kilometers from saturn
lies enceladus
smaller than our moon
enceladus is however one of saturn's
largest
satellites
this moon exhibits strange plumes
gazer-like formations which rise several
hundred kilometers above its surface
composed of particles of ice
gas
and dust
these jets of matter emerge from
cryovolcanoes scattered across the
surface of the satellite
they bear witness to an intense internal
activity
on its surface
enceladus is covered with ice
riddled with impact craters
and notched with cracks and volcanic
faults
this moon remains constantly in a frozen
state
at an average temperature of negative
200 degrees celsius
despite this very low surface
temperature
the geological activity of enceladus
betrays the existence of an ocean of
liquid water under the ice
as well as the presence of organic
compounds
[Music]
two ingredients essential
for the development of life
[Music]
we are now more than a million
kilometers away from saturn
it is at this distance that its largest
satellite orbits
titan
titan is home to a completely different
world from enceladus
surrounded by a very dense atmosphere
consisting mainly of nitrogen
we find here a very rich climate
with clouds
rains of methane
and even seasons
like on earth
this thick cloud layer hides a surface
with impressive variety
not entirely unlike some of the
landscapes found on earth
crossed by rivers and lakes of methane
titan is also speckled with volcanoes
mountains
and sand dunes
although frozen given its distance from
the sun
titan surprisingly recalls the first
moments of our planet
the chemical composition of its
atmosphere contains complex organic
molecules
which might remind us of the prebiotic
conditions
at the origin of life on earth
visible from earth
it has been observed since prehistoric
times
saturn has always fascinated astronomers
its gigantic size and majestic rings
make it a marvel of the solar system
better known today than ever before
it still holds many mysteries
which have yet
to be discovered
you